les 200 vols du fois dans ma vie je n'ai
jamais vu ça ils bétourné judy
gaudreault partait se reposer une
semaine à cuba avec les enfants dès leur
arrivée à l'aéroport de montréal trudeau
les ennuis commencent à 16 heures on
constate que vous observez encore
d'avions et on reçoit un message comme
quoi il va avoir un léger retard mais le
léger retard ces tirs
le départ est retardé au lendemain matin
on attend pratiquement trois heures
avant d'avoir nos bagages
ok mais après qu'on ait notre belize on
veut est ce qu'on a le droit d'aller
super est ce qu'on va voir une classe où
dormir est-ce qu'on doive retourner la
maison bref on n'était pas capable
d'avoir une version cohérente de
l'histoire six heures plus tard sunwing
dirige des clients vers un hôtel à 7h45
le lendemain matin l'avion fuient dit
pas redécollé après plus de deux heures
de retard
le vol de retour ne se passe pas mieux à
cuba le départ est retardé de plus de
trois heures en vol les passagers
apprennent que l'avion ait détourné vers
hamilton en ontario
parti trop tard de cuba l'avion ne peut
atterrir de nuit à montréal puisque
c'est interdit
sunwing a refusé notre demande
d'entrevue on dirait qu'on veut se laver
les mains de la situation le cofondateur
de vols en retard
une entreprise qui accompagnent les
passagers mécontents dans leurs
démarches pour obtenir une compensation
reconnaît qu'en juin dernier
les 150 passagers de sunwing n'avait pas
droit à grand chose
c'est le simple bon gloin d'ammonium est
mort en décembre dernier
le deuxième volet de la charte des
voyageurs est entrée en vigueur
elle force les compagnies à offrir des
indemnités aux passagers ça va jouer de
400 à 1000 $ donc si on parle en
attendent plus de neuf ans donc ce
serait me le rend par passager mais pour
y avoir droit il faut prouver la
responsabilité du transporteur
est-ce que sunwing pourraient être tenus
responsables selon la recharge
si votre départ de cuba est retardée
parce que le vol en train est en retard
entre guillemets ce n'est pas la faute
du transporteur où c'est moins neuf ou
dix transporteurs depuis la mise en
application de la charte des voyageurs
l'office des transports du canada a reçu
plus de six mille plaintes pour ce qui
est des passagers de sunwing
certains ont reçu un remboursement de
300 dollars et des excuses de
l'entreprise
il s'initie desjardins radio canada
montréal